foreign
[Music]
agents we've recovered five of the
hostages taken in the attack on the
White House but with each member of our
community we learned Natalia Circle over
is not the murderous psychopath we
assumed I don't know if it's General
Anderson's influence on her organization
or if spending her life on a move is
starting to get to her but it appears
that the black tasks have adopted true
Sun's tactics and are starting to shore
up infrastructure
what that something is it's too early to
tell without Vic as Murray says he knows
her operation he helped build it agents
if we want to rebuild the castle and
know what Circle over is really up to we
need to get Vic and unmask the asset